the freezing temperatures have disrupted
large parts of the country nowhere more
than Baltimore students there were kept
home this week not because they couldn't
get to school but because the buildings
were barely warmer than a refrigerator
Michelle Miller has more the conditions
inside Baltimore's Public Schools this
week were so frigid you had to see it to
believe it
I'm here in school with my two coats
because it's freezing
which is why teachers like Kira goo'bye
yuta a Frederick Douglass High School
posted videos showing buckled floors and
burst pipes they flooded the first day
and I moved to another class and then
that class flooded former NFL linebacker
Aaron Maybin may have gotten used to
playing on the frozen tundra you got a
call but it's not a lesson Maybin now a
Baltimore elementary school teacher
expected to teach his students some
Baltimore schools got as cold as 44
degrees indoors before schools were
closed Thursday and Friday dr. Sonya
Santa Lisa's is the CEO of Baltimore
City Schools some of this is about also
taking into account that young people
need to be fed that we have a lot of
young people who are frankly safer in
school then they are out since 2009 the
school system is returned roughly 66
million dollars in state funding for
repairs according to the Baltimore Sun
that's because contracts did not comply
with regulations but the schools tell
CBS News that's misleading and say
specific requests for school heating
systems including one for Douglas High
School were deferred by the state I'm
outraged at the failures in Baltimore
City Maryland governor Larry Hogan
disagrees and blames the city for
mismanagement they're one of the few
jurisdictions in a state that hasn't
addressed these problems in spite of the
fact that I believe they may be the most
highly funded school system in America
it was almost as cold in there as it is
out here right now for now there will be
an early more
temperature check at each Baltimore
school so decisions too close can be
made on an individual basis rather than
at the district level for CBS this
morning Saturday
I'm Michelle Miller it's a proud
graduate of the public school system
this is absolutely unacceptable in the
finger-pointing needs to end and someone
needs to get those kids it's a disgrace
all the kids are victims it's wrong